where did the idea of force come from
the whole thing in Star Wars was to take
again ideas psychological ideas from
social issues political issues spiritual
issues and condense them down into a an
easy to tell story of those stories the
force basically came from you know
distilling all of the religious beliefs
spiritual beliefs go all around the
world all through time finding the
similarities and then creating a and
easy to deal with metaphor for what
religion is and the point was is that
the I'm in the very beginning when you
have people worshipping rocks and deer
they called it life force they called it
the force that's what it was and so
where did the name come from it came
from basically life force of what the
more primitive religions believed in and
then you go through all the other
religions and they have the same thing
you know that it's all the same you know
whether you believe in God don't believe
in God believe in religion don't believe
in rigid the issue is that you either
don't believe there's anything else out
there which is a little I think would be
hard to live with at the same time I
mean I believe something's out there I
just don't know what it is I have no
idea or what I dare to guess but I do
know the religions are based on it their
human psychological needs that have been
put together mostly to create a society
Star Wars and in your unit channels were
basically put together especially Star
Wars more than Indiana Jones any other
Jones was just done for fun to entertain
people and there were some messages in
there about you know
archeology and also about what we
believe in in terms of myths and I sort
of thing but the real one is Star Wars
and that was done in the same vein that
what I was saying about the the the
patron creates the propaganda and what I
wanted to do is go back to some of the
older propaganda which was consistent
through all the societies which is
mythology but to say what did they all
believe because they were all this
propaganda it was created independently
yeah and what is one of the things that
they all actually believed we're talking
relationships with your father
relationships with your society
relations your history relationships
with the gods all this stuff is it's old
but their psychological motifs that were
created through storytelling primarily
oral storytelling that explained what
they believed it and who they believed
in so what I wanted to do is go back and
find the psychological motifs that
underlie that because those grow out of
popular ISM and to say that not all but
a majority of people boys have a certain
psychological relationship with their
fathers and that's been going on through
history and trying to explain that to
say we know your darkest secret yeah and
therefore you're part of us because we
all know the same things we know what
you're thinking about your mother we
know what you think about your brother
we know what you think about your father
really and those are the things that
make people say hey this is why we
believe this stuff and again the the
crudest part of that in terms of the
religious spiritual thing if some people
have taken those ideas and then
distorted them and you end up in a cult
where they're using the psychological
tools to make you adhere to their
society and part of it is they have to
keep it closed and
and to them and but in but it's the same
thing I mean and again you go through
history you know and even though in most
case you've had open societies but they
really weren't because let's face it you
had you were gonna killed if you go
outside the wall so let's build a wall
around the whole thing so we could
defend ourselves so they were
self-fulfilling you know isolated human
events